new facts are emerging out of the texas
elementary school where that awful
shooting took place this week and these
new facts somehow make the whole thing
even more horrible because they suggest
that the horror might have been
prevented we're talking about simple
facts here
the doors to the school were unlocked
the killer entered through an
unmonitored door in the back
there was no armed guard on duty
anywhere on the school premises
had even just those circumstances been
different of course it's no guarantee
that the shooter would have been stopped
or that the death toll would have been
lower
but it certainly would have reduced the
likelihood that the shooter could have
done what he did
and it's precisely these sorts of facts
that activists in the media are trying
to deny
i say this this tonight with the hope
not with an expectation but with the
hope
that people like ted cruz and greg
abbott and john cornyn people who were
elected by texans will actually listen
to it instead of going right to gun
control laws don't work and we need
armed teachers and guards at schools if
your solution to children being
massacred is armed guards
you haven't been paying attention to
what's going on
there was an armed guard in buffalo
there was an armed guard in parkland
there was an armed guard in ivaldi they
had armed guards
so what jimmy kimmel just said is not
true it's not true with with regard to
this shooting that we just saw in texas
it's i'm not even saying he's lying he
probably just doesn't know
but that falsehood and for some people
that lie is essential to the agenda and
the agenda here is not so much about
improving the safety of schools as it is
about enacting the mostly unrelated gun
control laws that liberals have wanted
for decades all the very same laws that
as even the washington post admits
wouldn't have stopped the mass shootings
there are lots of gun laws that
democrats want and that republicans and
voters more broadly actually will never
let them pass
for sure there are
there are plenty of gun laws that
republicans want that democrats won't
let them pass that's true too
but then there are really basic laws
that theoretically could be passed
that would go a long way toward
protecting schools funding armed guards
upgrading school buildings to better
secure the doors these are not
particularly ideological reforms these
are not an opportunity to score big
partisan points these are just basic
safety precautions to protect schools
which is why we are almost certainly not
going to get them not everything has to
be
an extreme partisan fight practically
speaking i guess it does these days but
it shouldn't have to be a big partisan
fight there are some really basic
things about society that we can all
agree on
i would hope at least that until very
recently we could all agree on
a leftist would not want to use this
tumbler to drink delicious tears or
sparkling water or whatever you're
drinking right they wouldn't want to use
this tumbler because it says leftist
tears just like i wouldn't want to use a
tumbler that says conservative tears
but at the very least we should both be
able to agree that you should drink
sparkling water out of a cup rather than
out of i don't know a kazoo
right there there are basic facts about
reality that we should all be able to
agree on that don't necessarily need to
have a republican color or a democrat
color or a left or right or not
everything has to be about ideology
the reason it feels like it does is
because the left's political program
is about upending society the left's
political program is essentially
revolutionary that's been true not just
for the past 20 years it's been true
going back to the french revolution it's
been it's been true further back than
that that we've got to remake the whole
world anew
and and all
of the inherited wisdom of the past it's
not wisdom it's all it's it's terrible
it's awful it's bigoted it's it's making
us all miserable we got to get rid of it
but there is a lot of wisdom in the past
we actually have learned things over the
history of humanity really basic things
it doesn't necessarily need to be about
rights and entitlement and high-minded
philosophy it can just be hey lock the
doors hey lock the doors when you want
to stay safe
hey have have single points of entry hey
have people whose job it is to protect
other people when they're a soft target
really really simple stuff there was a
an interview in chicago took place
yesterday or the day before this was
conducted by a fox affiliate in chicago
so not not fox news the center right
news channel but just a regular old
network affiliate
they're conducting the interview on the
street about guns in chicago during the
interview some dude comes out and
brandishes a pistol at the cameraman
around seven o'clock this morning at the
corner of clark and hubbard while our
reporter was in the middle of a live
report about gun violence in chicago a
man walked up and pointed what appeared
to be a firearm at our crew right now
police are calling this man a person of
interest accused of aggravated assault
with a firearm
this guy who brandished the gun on the
street at the reporter he doesn't look
like he's been living on the street for
the past two years he doesn't look like
necessarily some schizophrenic drug
addicted derelict roaming the streets
he's fairly well dressed he seems fairly
clean he's
he doesn't seem sane in that no sane
person should be brandishing a weapon on
the street but really he just seems
he seems bold
he seems like he knows there aren't
going to be any consequences for this
kind of behavior and why because there
won't be
because throughout many of our major
cities
run by leftists people are not arrested
for crimes
because for the past two years the left
has run on defunding the police and
abolishing police departments and
installing far-left da's that just won't
prosecute people for crime and then
during covet they emptied out the jails
and they just say we're they're they're
sending a message to the criminals hey
do whatever you want we're not going to
stop you
so is it any wonder that people like
this are emboldened in chicago do you
know what would stop this kind of
behavior it doesn't need to be some pie
in the sky really extremely
sophisticated ideological thing
arrest the criminals arrest him that
dude should be nabbed immediately he
should go to jail for a long time he
should be punished not just a little
plea deal slap on the hand well society
failed him well he had a tough
upbringing and let's just divert him
into a nice special non-profit program
where no punish him he's a bad guy and
if you don't want him to remain a bad
guy if you want him to become a better
guy then punish him
enforce basic laws is that so much to
ask these days i guess it is
because because none of the people now
who are clamoring do something do
something do something
none of them seem to care at all about
fixing the problems that they're
claiming to want to fix they're all just
pushing the same old ideological agenda
that they were pushing
ten months ago two years ago ten years
ago joe biden now
has gone off and
made this entire effort to which should
be about protecting schools into an
effort to ban ar-15s
no one needs an ar-15
something designed for no other purpose
none other than to kill human beings
there's no other rationale for its
existence
and they kill them as quickly and as
brutally as possible
it's not exactly true because you can
kill squirrels with an ar-15 or you
could i fear i think you could even kill
deer though it wouldn't be particularly
uh humane
but to his
it's also
ar-15s are not the quickest way to kill
people because they're not contrary to
what the left would have you believe
they're not fully automatic weapons
they're not assault rifles right a fully
automatic weapon you pull the trigger
and a spray of bullets comes out a
semi-automatic weapon you pull the
trigger one bullet comes out you pull
the trigger again another bullet comes
out so
what he's saying technically is is not
true but to his broader point he says
these guns kill people
and and he's implying that that's a bad
thing for guns to do that is the purpose
of guns that is the purpose of the
second amendment that is the purpose of
the right to self-defense
is that if someone comes to attack you
you have the right to defend yourself
that's what they're for people are not
buying these guns to go hunt squirrels
and he's insinuating that this is a bad
thing
what is his solution what is his
solution
if he's saying that the problem with the
ar-15 is they're designed to kill people
then that means we have to get rid of
all the guns
but not just the ar-15s handguns are
designed to kill people
in fact handguns are much more directly
designed to kill people than any of the
rifles are or any of the shotguns are
so then you have to get rid of all the
guns are you going to do that joe biden
no you'd have to repeal the second
amendment are you going to do that no
you can't do that and most people don't
want you to do that
so what are you gonna do are you going
to
are you going to pass laws
in contravention of the second amendment
are you going to try to change the
interpretation of the second amendment
are you going you're going to just
confiscate all the guns without
repealing the second amendment there are
more guns than people in america
so what is the practical effect of what
he's proposing
nothing
philosophically it's incoherent
constitutionally it's incoherent legally
it's incoherent but even put all that
aside those are the ideological debates
and the phyllis
just practically it's not going to
happen it's completely
fantastical
so then what does he do he's not doing
anything he's running his mouth and he's
trying to score cheap campaign points
but in practice he is accomplishing
absolutely nothing productive
so glad you like that clip now bing bang
boom subscribe like ring the bell do
whatever you got to do subscribe to the
michael knowles show on youtube and
everywhere else we'll see you next time
[Music]